everyone this is Randy here we are at
this special nintendo lab event to
actually test this thing out with the
target audience children this is
sebastian he's eight years old
sebastian what is this year holding
we're at this special nintendo lab event
in san francisco testing out this thing
with the target audience an
eight-year-old that gives the sebastian
and he just fell off the chair we're
gonna make some nintendo lab and stuff
right now and tell you what he thinks
about ok one two steps to complete okay
step one making the RC car and antenna
I'm deliberately not helping you
Sebastian oh cool so far did you tab all
the way in okay has been easy so far
[Music]
going to play or do you want to
customize it first
don't put the Drake button yet then you
guys can take a card you gonna go in
your own okay
[Music]
snicker man yeah how dare you yeah you
ready already
all right Sebastian if you have to guess
how long did it take you to finish that
remote-control car
one two three minute one two three
minutes probably closer to 1,500 saying
in your mouth hey there you go energy
[Music]
and the grommet what is a grommet okay
[Music]
baby bear is done I have good see I do
not need me back
you don't Oh we'll see about that
I like his father
what that's medium size oh my god that's
gonna be a nightmare
[Music]
Wow all right is itcool
chummy well done beat slow big pasta bit
faster
okay bit faster again gonna slow okay
we've just played about three hours of
lab Oh Sebastian was about three hours
what was your favorite those other stuff
there was a motorcycle there was a piano
what about the robot you did the robot
as well that's pretty cool right
okay that was not the control - okay
what about the all the stuff they said
about how you can make your own stuff in
Toyko garage so cool okay but you didn't
find it too hard like building all that
stuff do you think you could do it
yourself do you think you need like a
grown-up to help you do it okay okay so
if you had to say in one line what you
think of lava what would it be one line
[Music]
recommended for ages 6 and up okay there
you go you're headed from Sebastian I
think it's a it's a yes it's a yes okay
so for more level coverage keep checking
games book
you